This lesson is about
parallel algorithms for
sorting in the dynamic
multi-threading model.
There are two parts.
The first part consists of the
videos,which cover the idea of a sorting
network.
You can think of a sorting network as
a special kind of circuit that sorts.
It's a topic that's not usually
covered in your standard undergraduate
Algorithms 101 class.
So I hope that many of you will find
it interesting and, heaven forbid,
even a little fun.
Now separate from the video part,
I also want you to read a short
chapter on parallel merge sort.
I hope you'll find this reading helpful.
It should reinforce the main
ideas behind the dynamic
multi-threading model.
You'll also see some additional
techniques to analyze algorithms in
this model more formally.